[Música]
Hola soy Natalia Cabrera parada y les
doy la bienvenida aquí a América este es
el magazine de France 24 para revisar en
profundidad las noticias y las historias
de nuestro continente y esto es lo que
veremos hoy el presidente de Brasil el
ultraderechista Yahir bolsonaro se
enfrentará en segunda vuelta por el
cargo de mayor poder al izquierdista de
expresidente Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva
el 30 de octubre les explicamos los
retos del próximo inquilino del Palacio
de plan alto pero el partido de
bolsonaro bautizado partido liberal
dominará el congreso los conservadores
tendrán la mayor bancada de la cámara de
diputados mientras que en el senado la
mayoría de los 513 asientos están entre
el centro y la extrema derecha
y nos quedamos en Sudamérica para hablar
de Colombia y de Venezuela el paso de
dos camiones sobre el puente
internacional Simón Bolívar selló la
reapertura de la frontera un paso del
presidente colombiano Gustavo Petro por
superar la ruptura en los vínculos
diplomáticos
y vamos de inmediato a Brasil para
nuestra historia principal eran 11 los
aspirantes a la presidencia pero la
contienda era claramente un cara a cara
entre el actual presidente de
ultraderecha Yair bolsonaro y el ex
presidente de izquierda Luis Ignacio
Lula da Silva Lula no obtuvo los votos
necesarios para ganar en primera vuelta
por lo que deberá enfrentar nuevamente a
bolsonaro el próximo 30 de octubre
bolsonaron un escéptico de la pandemia y
hay quien a menudo se le llama el Trump
suramericano mostró más fuerza de la que
pronosticaban las encuestas y quedó solo
5 puntos porcentuales por debajo del ex
mandatario el presidente acusa a Lula de
haber liderado el gobierno más corrupto
de la historia del país Lula dejó el
cargo en 2010 con una tasa de aprobación
del 80%. Esto fue antes de ser
encarcelado por corrupción una condena
que luego anuló la Corte Suprema
Mientras que el ex mandatario acusa a
bolsonaro de destruir el país y su
legado
siempre creí que íbamos a ganar estas
elecciones y lo que puedo decir es que
vamos a ganar estas elecciones
esto es solo una prórroga sabes
lo importante en la segunda vuelta son
las propuestas para la sociedad
la confianza total la confianza porque
se desenmascararon de una vez las
encuestas datafolia nos situaba en 51
frente al 30 y pico la diferencia fue de
cuatro puntos entonces todo eso ayuda a
que el voto se vaya para el otro lado
quien sea que seguramente como el
próximo presidente de Brasil en enero
enfrentará los mismos retos que les
explicamos en el siguiente informe
dos hombres con visiones diametralmente
diferentes para su país el izquierdista
Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva salió del
Palacio de plan alto en 2010 como el
presidente más popular de la historia de
Brasil Aunque su reputación se vio
manchada después por acusaciones de
corrupción sigue siendo recordado como
que sacó a millones de personas de la
pobreza Brasil enfrenta niveles de
hambruna no vistos en 30 años por lo que
Lula está prometiendo llevar al país de
regreso a ese periodo un país el país
que es un país que la gente extraña un
país con trabajo un país donde la gente
tenía derecho a vivir con dignidad con
la cabeza en alto y este país volverá
Lula ha prometido reformar el sistema
tributario para poner la carga
impositiva sobre los más ricos y obtener
un mayor presupuesto Estatal políticas
económicas que son Exactamente lo
contrario de las del actual mandatario
Yair bolsonaro que apoya una plataforma
neoliberal de mayor privatización y se
negó a cerrar la economía de Brasil
durante la pandemia del coronavirus lo
que provocó miles de muertes bolsonaro
ha tratado de ganarse a los votantes de
escasos recursos Con dinero en efectivo
mientras pinta a Lula como un comunista
corrupto;
sabemos que el comunismo conduce a la
desgracia la pobreza el hambre y la no
queremos eso para nuestro Brasil
[Música]
Los Seguidores del líder de extrema
derecha son en su mayoría fanático
religiosos Defensores del porte de armas
así como de la industria agrícola los
agricultores aprecian su eliminación de
la protección de los territorios
indígenas mientras que los evangélicos
se sientan atraídos por su Campaña
centrada en la defensa de la familia
tradicional bolsonaro a estado sembrando
dudas sin fundamentos sobre el sistema
de votación electrónico de Brasil lo que
genera temores de que se negaría a
aceptar la derrota sus críticos ahora
dicen que la democracia está en juego
debemos trabajar para ganar el voto de
todos los que aman la democracia
bolsonaru Un capitán retirado del
ejército buscó el respaldo de los
militares para sus afirmaciones
infundadas de fraude electoral e instó a
sus seguidores a armarse desde que
relajó las leyes de arma de fuego de
Brasil en 2019 la posición de armas se
ha disparado
y tenemos que luchar contra La Pandilla
de Lula lucharemos y repito el pueblo
armado jamás será esclavizado
la violencia política no es nueva en
Brasil el propio evolucionario fue
apuñalado en la campaña electoral de
2018 pero esta campaña ha estado marcada
por incidentes violentos con varios
simpatizantes de Lula heridos y un
funcionario asesinado por simpatizantes
de bolsonaro los mismos candidatos han
estado usando chalecos antibalas en
público según una encuesta reciente casi
el 70% de los brasileños dicen que temen
ser agredidos físicamente debido a su
afiliación política y a pesar de que
Lula obtuvo la mayoría de los votos en
la elección presidencial en esta primera
vuelta la formación de bolsonaro del
partido liberal tendrá la mayoría en la
cámara de diputados con 99 escaños Y
aunque la izquierda logró algunos
avances como la elección de las primeras
diputadas trans e indígenas el congreso
seguirá siendo mayoritariamente
masculino blanco y de derecha desde Río
de Janeiro nuestra corresponsal Valeria
saccone nos explicaba Cómo quedó la
composición del congreso
ahí vemos que bolsonaro ha salido
totalmente reforzado porque ha
conseguido elegir a ocho senadores
frente a los cuatro del partido de los
trabajadores Y entonces en el senado
tendrá el grupo parlamentario más grande
de su historia nos referimos al partido
liberal que representa a bolsonaro lo
mismo pasa en el congreso donde han
elegido a 99
diputados según los datos parciales y
tendrán también el grupo parlamentario
más fuerte lo que es muy importante en
un país que no es 100% presidencial
Brasil es un semi presidencialismo donde
las dos cámaras del parlamento tienen un
peso muy grande otro dato que muestra
cuánto bolsionares fuertes todos sus ex
aliados que se han alejado de él no han
sido elegidos en el congreso ni en el
senado y finalmente Sergio Moro el juez
que mandó Lula a la cárcel ha sido
elegido como senador junto a otros
representa de la investigación la
bachata lo que también demuestra que una
parte de Brasil no se fía de Lula y no
ha olvidado los escándalos de corrupción
cambiamos de tema y nos venimos a
Colombia que le abrió la puerta
nuevamente al comercio con Venezuela y
con el paso de dos camiones sobre el
puente internacional Simón Bolívar que
une a la ciudad colombiana de Cúcuta con
la venezolana de San Antonio del táchira
dieron un primer paso hacia la
normalización de sus relaciones
diplomáticas y comerciales el 26 de
septiembre ambos países abrieron el paso
al transporte de carga después de años
de relaciones congeladas
un equipo de Francia 24 se trasladó
hasta la frontera entre ambas naciones
para conocer qué expectativas tienen sus
habitantes sobre esta nueva etapa en la
relación bilateral el informe es de
Daniela Blandón herminia Fernández y
haitiador chávarry
a Óscar Cardoza a sus clientes no lo
tienen que buscar él sale a su encuentro
en la multitud desde esta caótica
frontera que une a Colombia y Venezuela
el cierre de este paso en 2015 significó
para muchos la quiebra pero este
caraqueño jubilado de la Universidad de
Venezuela ayudó en él una oportunidad
que le ha dado sustento en los últimos
años con la misma necesidad la persona
de transportarse de san antonio acá y de
aquí a San
Antonio a la parada y a la parada San
Antonio porque eso porque no había
manera había que pasar bien por lo menos
él es una persona que no difícil que
cruza el puente el gobierno venezolano
de Nicolás maduro y el colombiano del
entrante Gustavo Petro también de a la
izquierda acordaron una normalización de
relaciones en una primera etapa incluyó
la reapertura del paso de carga mi
patria lo necesita
No importa que el trabajo se pueda
acabar por aquí por la frontera
pero no no antes necesitamos que
que esa economía de Venezuela se oxigena
un poquito por el momento la medida no
incluye el tránsito de carros
particulares ni de transporte
intermunicipal y personas como él
algunos cargados con enormes bultos
deben seguir Cruzando el puente
internacional Simón Bolívar a pie y con
horarios restringidos nada Bienvenido a
Venezuela
pero lo que para uno es una luz de
Esperanza otros lo ven con un optimismo
discreto Olga Muñoz administra una
empresa de transporte en el lado
colombiano de la frontera de aquí a
Pamplona y de Pamplona hasta ipiales yo
soy una mujer de 57 años que desde los
23 años estoy trabajando antes desde los
17 años trabajo y vivo en Venezuela yo
soy una inmigrante más salí de última
pero o sea Nos tocó salir por la
situación Confía en que el panorama
podría ser distinto pero en el fondo lo
que Espera es un cambio político en
Venezuela que el gobierno
se termine de irse vaya con la verdad de
otra manera no me parece que fue un como
algo de protocolo que pasó el camión con
los cables del acero y ya de repente me
va a mejorar en el sentido de que va a
poder a mis hermanos venezolanos comprar
unas cositas acá pero está la guardia
nacional al otro lado cierto Y qué hace
la guardia nacional cuando usted lleva
un bultico de Mercado
aparte de que le sale más caro entonces
la guardia nacional va a querer que
usted pague impuesto de lo poquito que
usted está llevando
como Óscar y Olga otras 30.000 personas
cruzan a diario esta frontera invisible
otros miles lo hacen y es posible que
por un buen tiempo más por las rutas
ilegales hoy más vivas que nunca en una
frontera común que se extiende a lo
largo de 2217 kilómetros
y sigamos hablando de Colombia y es que
alrededor de 300 joyas precolombinas
fueron repatriadas desde Estados Unidos
joyas que tienen miles de años y que
fueron sacadas de manera ilegal del país
el presidente colombiano Gustavo Petro
fue el encargado de regresarlas cuando
viajó desde Nueva York a donde asistió
para la asamblea general de la ONU hasta
Bogotá gracias por acompañarme en esta
emisión de aquí a América por favor
envíenme sus comentarios en redes
sociales a la dirección que ven en su
pantalla pueden ver esta emisión y las
anteriores en nuestra página web tras
24.com
[Música]